this presentation will
talk about some new features for version
10.
for the new version we now support text
mapping
for field curve we add a bunch of new
primitives
including inside 3d and
a bunch of other region
primitives and we have new options to
support
3d clipping
okay so how does that work
like other primitives you need to
specify
texture and also given the texture
coordinates
vertex texture coordinates is also an
option for field curve so
here's the example
uh the options the texture
conic is specified corresponding to
control points
and it will be interpolated
to those curve points
here is a multi-segment
example so you can specify
here altogether
this is multiple object form you can
also
specify within the segment
this is a much easier but this is a way
much
much easier to read
and for further curve we also
have encoded a way
which is used by some functions like
import string export string for the
reason of
efficiency so
like here you need to specify the
segment
types but here what you need to do
bunch of integers
you can encode those types with
0 one two zero is line one is
basic curve two is a b spline curve
the second argument here is
uh the number of control points around
the path
and the spline degree the third one is
spelling degree
so here is the path and
then come with the options
so here is the example how do we apply
texture or pattern to to fonts
so the idea is to convert
fonts to fill the curves and
mathematical has functions to do that
so just just specify the
texture coordinates and then you can get
different results
um so
same idea for those parameters currently
don't
support the texture mapping like a disk
you can do the same thing
and convert it and then
apply the pattern
here is a actually it the disk is turned
into fear the curves
so here's a bunch of other examples
here is the result of
plot functions and the new primitives
country data
freehand painting and some
image processing results so you can
apply texture to
all of them which means
anything so same thing
you can do that to outline as
as well now we assign a pattern
different pattern
and these are actually just a bunch of
lines
so you need to do is just x
convert it to field join curve and then
and change replace it with field curve
and then specify
the texture coordinates
okay so so this gives
a weight a field curve gives a way to
let you apply pattern to to a lot of
different things
so here we
support inset is a very useful
primitive that allows allows you to put
a
graphics into a different one this
brings a lot of flexibility
and however for version 9
and before it only supports by graphics
but for the new version we now it it now
works with
graphics 3d as well
then you can set a 2d graphics
expression into 3d
and it works way in the beer boarding
way
here's the example you can put a
2d disc inside
3d space it has a depth perception
and the position is
the one you specified
and it also works with type setting as
well
i want to mention that this is not a
texture or
image it's the original fonts
and same thing here the disk is
is the vector
you can also insert a
insert controls as well
like a button
and if it is occluded
it is not active
so with this new feature you can do
a lot of interesting things and to to 3d
graphics
like you can bring
to the animations in 3d
and you can also do like a
particle system and then navigation
inside as well
okay and we for the new version we
introduced a bunch of new
symbols for uh for regions
and you can do computing on them
and they also work with graphics and
graphics 3d as well
here are some of the examples and
like a infinity line
and half line something
here so before version 9 and
version 9 before we can only specify
coordinates but with these new
primitives you can specify vectors as
well
in either one direction or both
directions
you can also specify angles as well ages
so here's the example
this is the half line infinite line half
plane
and they are computed dynamically based
on the plot range
and
konica region is a is a
super primitive actually all the half
line
influencer line are the special case for
this
primitive here's a correspondence
and also
in 3d conical region can use to
represent
like volumes as well
here's a bunch of different cases in 3d
it can be used to represent the point
and
volumes as well
and there are more primitives
due to the time limit and i'm not going
to
go to details one by one but
i'll take one example here like a
triangle you
you can specify just corners you can
also specify with edges
and angles and they
they should just work with with the
existing
directives and styling
and clippings we now have
three cd clipping for the new version
and through these two options
for graphics 3d clip planes and clip
playing star
style and the clip plane is
is a list of
points and it is defined in this way
and you can also choose to visualize the
clipping
plane itself through
this option and by default it is
false it is it's none
sorry and here's a manipulate
um shows that you can change control the
plane very
conveniently
and it does very fast
because it is hardware accelerated
you can choose not to shoot the plane
and see the the the the clipping plate
is computed
dynamically
it is a region concept but it is not a
region object
internally it does same thing like a
canonical regions
okay so here's the example of three
arrested 3d
um uh
the clipping tools can be very useful
for for wrestlers 3d
because this allows you to to see
clearly what's inside
and it goes very fast so we based on
this you can build up your own
customized
and your own way of clipping tools
so and other
than that we also have a bunch of new uh
we have a bunch of improvements and a
lot of bug fixes like uh
now plotter and pending because to all
kids is supported for for 3d graphics
and several new method options and
like john mentioned
for the for the new version we now
rasterize the
graphics 3d uh when export.pdf
this fixed a lot of bugs like
rendering artifacts and
under the file size and
there are some other other bug fixes as
well
so that will be
my talk